das ziemlich voll dunkel jetzt ist zu
hell
es ist wieder zu dunkel wahrscheinlich
so hey was geht ab und jetzt willkommen
bei anleihen video ja ich hab natürlich
euch geht's gut ich hab das nach einer
woche auch mal wieder geschafft mich
hinzusetzen und ein video für euch zu
drehen was auch ziemlich spontan ist
heute weil eigentlich wollte ich diesen
tag auch noch pause machen aber ich habe
heute eine sehr interessante challenge
eigentlich überlegt hast du einen keks
für dich aufgemacht gut auf jeden fall
habe ich gerade weibliche unterstützung
von marie heißt so alter ich kann
ehrlich nicht noch so komplett das nicht
trinken alkohol aber es ist irgendwie
echt schwer heute auf jeden fall haben
wir ebenso einfach mal was uns
interessiert hat geschaut wieviel so
stars was sie so an vermögen haben haben
wir also ein bisschen rum geschaut und
wir sind dann durch zufall auch auf so
youtuber gestoßen wie viel die halt
haben und dann habe ich gedacht
stoppt bevor wir jetzt weiter schaust
kannst du doch ein video darüber machen
weil ich meine ich mit meiner million
auf dem konto ich weiß ja ungefähr wie
viel man so verdient als youtube und
deswegen der polizei lang und deswegen
versuche ich das einfach mal bestmöglich
zu schätzen marie hat jetzt zehn
youtuber ausgesucht ich hoffe das sind
doch alles verlässliche zahlen das kann
man ja nie so sagen also wir reden
natürlich von youtube views von
placebase märz alles drum und dran also
wirklich das komplett gesamte vermögen
von den reichen youtube aus deutschland
und ich glaube auch welche von der
ganzen welt
juli zum beispiel hast ja auch ne dann
würde ich mal sagen dass mit der million
nur spaß eben und zweitens fangen jetzt
an oder hasst den keks aufgegessen und
ihr könnt natürlich auch fleißig in den
kommentaren mit rat und ich bin jetzt
mal gespannt ob ich das wirklich so gut
schätzen kann oder vielleicht sind die
zahlen ja auch kompletter müll
woher hast du das von bild de ok dann
fangen wir mal an mit alex w
400.000 euro wie du hast mich nicht
gefunden mich gibt es nicht ich hab noch
nicht genug geld dafür klein dass da
natürlich nur spaß so jetzt sag einmal
den ersten russen youtuber von wann ist
die quelle wurde das her hast okay aber
sie sollte auf jeden fall aus dem
letzten jahr seien also der ist ja auf
jeden fall schon ziemlich lange dabei
und kann ja anscheinend ziemlich viel
finanzieren ich weiß dass er glaube ich
auf seinem haupt kanal an die milliarden
views hat oder so das sind ja an sich
schon mal eine million ich will bei ihm
ist einfach mal schätzen 25 millionen
genau richtig echte als wenn hier lebt
von den 2,5 millionen okay dann wird es
ja ich sag mal so wenn die quelle jetzt
ein halbes jahr her ist wird das ja
passen
aber ich würde schon sagen ein bisschen
mehr eigentlich okay machen arbeiten wir
noch wie ich finde sowas immer so
interessant also an sich müsste sie auf
jeden fall über dem felix liegen weil
sie was beauty unseren blödsinn angeht
glaube ich richtig fesch abstaubt auch
wenn sie jetzt keine eigene durchschaut
hat aber ich würde sagen ich will das
einfach mal schätzen 3 millionen was
denn
nein das kann nicht passen
war das von der gleichen quelle also da
muss ich als erfahrener youtuber einen
schon sofort ein haken das ist das kann
nicht stimmen so wird jetzt nichts
einfallen womit der felix mehr geld
macht als das vielleicht von den news ja
generell weil er früher für let's plays
gemacht hat ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr
finanzexperten so dazu sagt nein hat
also meiner meinung nach ist daher auf
jeden fall vor felix okay wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten
also er ist ja auch schon ultralange
dabei hat auch auf beiden kanälen
zusammen bestimmt schon über zwei
milliarden views ich weiß jetzt nicht
genau aber würde ich mal schätzen die
bewerben auch ihren märz ziemlich krass
ich glaube die wurden aber auch damals
beim mega kraft und ordentlich durch den
kakao gezogen deswegen
fällt also ein bisschen geld wert 2,5
millionen sagt auch 250 warm wie du bist
ach so also das kann wirklich passen
aber die sind da zu dritt das heißt
jeder hat halt nur hat sie sind nicht
mehr möglich wäre sehr voll schlecht
okay gibt es noch balkon gehört auf
jeden fall zu den reichsten würde ich
mal von ausgehen ist ja auch glaube ich
noch der meist abonniert ist die
deutsche kanal nach free kickers aber
das ist ja eigentlich mehr so ein
internationaler kanal und das ding bei
franck ist ich glaube der staub jetzt
nicht so krass ab was irgendwelche
großen placement angeht dafür aber auf
jeden fall durch klitsche streaming
plattform also da gibt es auch recht
viele youtuber wieder richtig krass cash
machen so ich habe auch schon überlegt
damit anzufangen aber dieses videos für
ein bisschen ein bisschen also wieso
oberflächlich als star bekommt ist was
so merge und pace uns angeht nicht so
ganz oben mit dabei aber auf jeden fall
was die usa angeht und dann noch twitch
kommt hinzu also auf jeden fall mehr als
felix 3 millionen sack ich in den wald
erwartet 3,5 millionen schon viel ist
damit erster so aus deutschland oder ist
bw.de oder die das komplexe noch babys
glaube ich also bei baby würde ich
ehrlich sagen allein schon wegen biel
und so das ist ja mega krass ich glaube
das wird sogar jetzt schon in england
eingeführt oder so hat also da gibt es
wirklich auch schon so viel und so weit
ich weiß ist das auch recht erfolgreich
allein damit wird die schon jeden hund
hatte ich weiß natürlich nicht wie viel
sie wirklich davon bekommt aber das
benutzen ja sogar ältere damen also
weißt du so ich hab mal so eine seine
frau kennengelernt die war irgendwie 540
agiert auch gesagt sie benutzt also
babys gesamtvermögen würde ich allein
schon deswegen und weil sie halt auch
beauty macht und die größte deutsche
youtube grenze auf 8 millionen schätzen
ich bin auch nicht dass die felder auf
jeden fall falsch ist weil da steht das
baby hinter also ich glaube bb ist auf
jeden fall was deutschland angeht die
krasseste und es ist auf jeden fall mehr
als merkwürdig also ich sage auf jeden
fall 8 millionen das falsch okay machen
irgendwie so ein machen ob julie payette
hin will ich jetzt mal und das ist auch
von der gleichen quelle also ich würde
bei paddy power auf jeden fall sagen
mein der typ hat glaube ich an die 60
millionen abonnenten allein schon durch
kriegs werden das über zehn millionen
sein und dann kommt natürlich auch noch
placement und so weiter dazu ich würde
bei dem so auf jeden fall sagen 50
millionen wenn nicht sogar mehr
ja irgendwie so und das kann auch nicht
stimmt also ich würde auf jeden fall
sagen piep als einer der reichsten
youtuber der welt und hat locker über 50
millionen locker aber es kann natürlich
auch von mir falsch sein was ich sage
nur ich denke mal dass ich mich da
eigentlich ganz gut auskennen und auch
so weiß was halt größere youtuber in
deutschland so wirklich verdienen wenn
man das dann halt so hoch rechnet vor
allem in amerika zum beispiel ist das
geld was man für 1000 klicks bekommen
meistens auch noch mal höher als in
deutschland
deswegen würde ich auf jeden fall sagen
juli feiert schon 250 millionen auf dem
konto wie viel geld an sicher dass ja
immer so mit dem hobby angefangen und ok
ich würde sagen ein noch also die beiden
sagen mir immer sie wollen eigentlich
mehr so als musiker geld noch nicht
youtuber und ich glaube sie machen auch
auf jeden fall mehr geld mit mit mit
musik als mit youtube-videos scheint
also die kinder so denken was ich
schätze so bei denen würde ich auch auf
jeden fall so 23
was steht mir
was steht was habe ich gesagt ja ich
kann ja aber ich kann ja so sagen was
ich kann ja so schätze ich denke was
steht denn ich glaube auch mehr allein
schon durch die musik fallen die haben
ja auch so viele auftritt und so ok und
zum schluss noch ein
karl als genau den wollen wir auf jeden
fall noch ich weiß nicht ob den viele
von euch kennen aber der ist auch durch
die typ bekannt geworden und er macht
halt so fitnessvideos hat auch sein
eigenes fitnessprogramm und von dem habe
ich auch schon vieles gehört und ich
würde da auch auf jeden fall zweieinhalb
millionen sagen 5 millionen alter kreis
dann hat er ja sogar mehr als krank wie
es dasteht so weist also in der fitness
her kenne ich mich jetzt nicht wirklich
aus aber ich weiß dass da viele auch
durch durch fitnessprogramme
ernährungspläne und so weiter echt viel
geld machen ja das war meine schätzung
des video ich hoffe ja und ich mit
geschätzt in den kommentaren ich wenn es
auf jeden fall schon groß ist das denn
also ich finde es auf jeden fall schon
krass wie sich youtube so entwickelt hat
eigentlich es mir kalt und wie viel geld
so hier durch die gegend fließt jeden
tag oder bezahlt wird für irgendwelche
werbung er das themenfeld habe mich
irgendwie eben sehr interessiert und
deswegen habe ich dieses video gemacht
danke auch an marias du dass du nicht
raus besucht hast also ich hoffe
natürlich auf alle tasten für
interessant was ist aber morgen gibt es
ein cooles video also wir sehen uns
morgen wieder
ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag gibt
nach rom checkt instagram slapshot ab
und fängt an mit youtube ein spaß das
ist natürlich komplett falsch mit
youtube anzufangen weil man denkbar
verdienen die viel ich will auch so viel
verdienen als ich angefangen habe konnte
man auf youtube nicht mal geld verdienen
zum beispiel also wir sehen uns haben